Some video games have compelling characters,
great stories, and epic plot twists.
Others…
don't, leaving us with more disappointment
and questions than answers.
Sure, every great game may have a few, small
storytelling inconsistencies, but others are
just plain inexcusable.
Here are a few the worst of the worst.
And be warned, spoilers ahead.
Final Fantasy VII
It's safe to assume Final Fantasy VII is most
fans' favorite game in the series.
But one question has nagged even casual players
for ages: why didn't someone just use a Phoenix
Down on Aeris after she's killed by Sephiroth?
It's an item that literally brings someone
back to life, and they're used hundreds of
times throughout the series…
so why not Aeris?
Why not now?
Some might argue that Phoenix Downs can only
revive characters who are just NEAR death
— but let's really think about this.
Your heroes get pounded by boulders, burned
with fire magic, sliced with fridge-sized
swords, and eradicated by giant saw-boned
eels.
Is getting stabbed by Sephiroth's sword somehow
worse than all that?
Apparently.
But no one knows why.
Heavy Rain
Quantic Dreams' cinematic interactive drama
Heavy Rain is a unique experience, with a
great story and a twist nobody saw coming.
That said, it's also full of plot holes, including
one very major one we can't simply ignore.
Early in the game, we learn that central protagonist
Ethan Mars has blackouts following the death
of one of his sons.
He wakes up in seemingly random locations,
soaking wet, holding origami figures.
That sounds like pretty bad news when there's
an "Origami Killer" on the loose.
Does Ethan has some kind of split personality
serial killer disorder?
The problem is, after we learn what's really
going on, and who the Killer really is, Ethan's
blackouts and handfuls of origami are never
explained.
They just occur to distract and confuse the
player, and we never get to find out why,
making them seem like a pretty lame and obvious
attempt at throwing us off the trail.
Metroid
A classic Nintendo franchise, Metroid's premise
is awesome: you're a lady in a badass robotic
suit that kills aliens.
What's not to like?
There is one problem, though.
For a game series that prides itself on continuity
and realism, we've killed the dinosaur space
pirate Ridley a few too many times.
Even the most adept Metroid scholars have
a hard time explaining the constant reappearances
of Ridley, one of the series' most notorious
bosses.
Those who've played every Metroid game may
be forgiven for thinking that they've killed
Ridley almost a dozen times in Metroid, Super
Metroid, Metroid Prime, Metroid Prime 3, and
Metroid Fusion.
Apparently, the guy just didn't die in all
of those cases, and has been cloned multiple
times.
At least that's how Nintendo makes sense of
it all.
But maybe it's time to let poor Ridley rest
in peace.
Fallout 3
There's nothing quite like a massive plot
hole after a 60-plus hour trek through post-apocalyptic
nuclear wastelands.
At the end of Fallout 3, you're presented
with a choice: either you or your companion
have to enter an irradiated chamber.
But either way, somebody's going to get a
lethal dose of X-rays, and it's not going
to be pretty.
Those players rolling with the super mutant
companion Fawkes, however, were left wondering
why we couldn't send him into the chamber.
You know, considering he's immune to radiation.
It would basically be a leisurely stroll for
Fawkes, so why won't he just do what any normal
mutant would do?
Short answer: the game's developer, Bethesda,
decided to make Fawkes a super mutant jerk.
"Uhhhhh, I'm sorry my companion but, uh, no."
He refuses to enter the chamber, going on
about how he doesn't want to rob us of our
destiny and offering other bogus reasons,
none of which excuse the fact that he's immune
to radiation.
Bethesda eventually fixed the weird choice
with the Broken Steel add-on, but for fans,
the damage was done, and we were sent off
with a big ol' Fawkes you.
Red Dead Redemption
The open-world action-adventure Red Dead Redemption
is a master-class in game making, and easily
the best Western-themed video game ever made,
but it also illustrates the fact that no game
is perfect.
And there's one significant plot hole which
really made players scratch their ten-gallon
hats in bewilderment.
Everyone was bummed out when John Marston
died at the end of the main story.
Luckily, his son Jack shows up to save the
day three years later, doling out some revenge
and being an all-around badass — just like
his father.
The problem is, this turn of events poses
one major question: how in tarnation did book-readin'
intellectual Jack Marston turn into a gunslinger
on par with his dad in only three years?
Marston Senior surely cultivated that precision
aim and those legendary skills after a lifetime
of being an outlaw, in addition to all the
shenanigans we actually have control over.
We have to assume that Jack, presumably still
in his late teens, acquires every one of his
father's talents, without his father to teach
him, in just three short years.
We're calling bullchips on this one.
Crysis 2
In the first Crysis, we learn the hard way
that a race of invading aliens can actually
absorb nuclear energy — like the kind that
comes from nuclear weapons — which makes
them more powerful than ever.
Who knew, right?
So when it came time for the sequel, one might've
assume there'd be no nuking of aliens.
Defying all logic and common sense, the military
in Crysis 2 orders a nuclear strike on New
York City in an attempt at eradicating the
same alien threat, basically pretending the
first game never happened.
It's not even a minor oversight; the latter
portion of the second game is based entirely
around nuking New York City with alien-fortifying
bombs.
You're basically dropping vitamins on them.
You'd think a failed nuking of an energy-absorbing
alien race wouldn't be something the military
would forget — but apparently in Crysis
2, that file got lost somewhere.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!